dr. Anthony Fauci the government's top
infectious disease expert warned last
night that we need to be prepared for a
possible second cycle of coronavirus
later this year Paula Reed is at the
White House was more on the story but
Paula what is the president saying a
good morning Gail the president clearly
wants to jumpstart the economy even
though economists health experts and
lawmakers on both sides of the aisle say
lifting the current restrictions could
cost lives with a little lasting benefit
for the economy I'm not going to do
anything rash or hastily I don't do that
but the country wants to get back to
work after saying Tuesday that he wanted
the country raring to go by Easter
president Trump yesterday appeared to
couch that goal instead suggesting a
staggered approach to sections of our
country there's big sections of our
country that are very you know little
affected by what's taking place then
there are other sections that are very
heavily affected so there's a big
difference but as cases continue to rise
some state leaders remain hesitant to
send people back to work we begin to
prematurely open things up
I believe we only throw gasoline on the
fire of the virus economists and
lawmakers on both sides of the aisle
have criticized his plan to open the
country in just two and a half weeks but
the president accused the media of
wanting to keep the country shut down in
order to hurt his chances of re-election
so you tweeted you said that the media
wants the country to remain closed I
think there are certain people that
would like it to do financially poorly
because they think that would be very
good as far as defeating me at the polls
there are people in your profession that
would like that to happen but even the
president's top medical experts have
warned against setting arbitrary
deadlines for resuming normal activities
you've got to be realistic and you've
got to understand that you don't make
the timeline the virus makes the
timeline so you've got to respond in
what you see happen you've got to go
with what the situation on the ground is
we know our viewers have a lot of
questions about how the virus will
continue to impact schools and the vice
president says education secretary Betsy
who rarely talks to journalists will
make her debut at the coronavirus
taskforce briefing on Friday Tony yeah a
lot of kids out of school but the virus
sets the timetable important note there
Paula thank you very much